Don't do the Marxists,
have sympathy for the working class.
Okay.
George Orwell was interested in this question and so he wrote this book called
Wagon Road to Wigan pier,
which I would highly recommend it.
It's on a reading list I made.
It's on my website.
You can check that out.
Those are books that have been particularly influential to me.
And so,
yeah,
well,
it was a socialist.
He wrote the book for the Left Book Club,
which published a kind of a socialist book once a month or,
well,
by the time he wrote this book,
he was already awake.
Okay.
You know,
by,
in the 1920s after the Russian revolution,
no one really knew what to make of what was happening in what would become the
Soviet Union.
Right.
Be,
it was after World War One planet was in ashes.
For all intents and purposes,
the old aristocratic order was crumbling.
MMM.
It was a horror show.
And these revolutionaries came out with these new ideas and tried to give the in
principle,
give the working class a break and everybody watched to see what would happen
then.
MMM.
The honest people and the intellectuals watched and I separate them for a
reason.
Um,
but by 19 2021,
22,
something like that,
it was obvious already that something was rotten in the state of Denmark.
Malcolm Muggeridge went over to the Soviet Union to check out how the
collectivization of the farms was going and he found out it was actually pretty
murderous,
right?
Because what this,
what the Communists did was round up all the successful farmers and rape them
and kill them and steal everything they had and send them off to Siberia,
which turned out actually to be a pretty bad idea.
Now you think you think about it,
those people were serfs not very long before,
a couple of generations at most.
And they were so not much more than slaves.
And some of them had risen up to the point where to me it had a nice brick house
and a couple of cows and maybe a person working for them or too,
and there was a small proportion of the agriculturalists in the Soviet Union
that we're producing most of the food.
And that's just how it goes.
Because that's a Prieto distribution issue.
In any field where there's human productivity,
a small proportion of the people produce almost all of the output.
It's actually the square root of the number of people in the field produce half
the output.
So if you have a hundred farmers,
10 of them produce half the food.
But if you have 10,000 to a hundred of them,
produce half the food.
Okay?
So what happens when you kill all the good farmers,
you starve 6 million Ukrainians to death in the 1930s.
And you know,
that's not something that's all that widely known.
But if you want to,
uh,
provide some additional fodder for your nightmares,
you could go online and read about what happened to the Ukrainians in the 1930s
so that underneath the,
under the collectivization principles,
so let's say you were a mother and you were starving to death and so are your
children.
And you know,
the communists had come in and forcibly collectivized you.
And then they took all the grain that your collective farm had produced and they
shipped it all to the city,
say,
and so that's all done.
And you think,
okay,
you know the city's got eat and so then you go out in the field to pick up the
grains that the harvesters missed so that you can,
you know,
the ones that they'd been lying there,
they're not so good.
There's not that many of them.
You go out and glean,
you pick up the seeds that weren't picked up.
Ah,
so you can feed your kids so they don't die.
And so what's the punishment for that death?
Because you were obliged under the collectivization orders to turn in any
additional grains that you happen to pick off the ground to the authorities so
that they could be,
well who knows,
but at least so you,
so they could be shipped to the cities,
I suppose,
which is of course absurd because of course that would never happen,
but it was mostly so that you could just actually die.
So,
okay.
Anyways,
back to the road to Wigan pier now.
Okay.
I'm going to read you a little bit about,
about from the book.
So or well went out to this mining town in the northern UK and coal miners.
Orwell had sympathy for the working class.
He really worked on that his whole life cause he was a middle class,
upper middle class,
snobby type Englishman.
And he knew it.
Um,
and he tried really hard to overcome that.
He,
he,
he served in the Spanish civil war.
He wandered around as a tramp.
He worked in,
in,
in low end restaurant.
He worked as a low end worker in restaurants in Paris and in London.
He has a very good book,
I think it's called down and out in Paris and London that describes that he was
seriously committed dude and really a smart guy.
And so he's going up to these terrible towns in the northern UK where the coal
miners worked and have their families and you know,
they had hard lives.
They had hard lives.
And that's just saying nothing.
You know,
the coal miners that he met,
they didn't have any teeth by the time they were 30.
He said the women he talked to said teeth or just a misery.
It's better to get rid of them as soon as you can.
Um,
and,
and they went and the man went and mined coal and that was rough.
You know,
they all have black lung by the time they were 40 and they were,
they were done fundamentally.
But here's a,
just a bit,
a bit of a story about how hard their lives were.
So they had to go in the minds during the day so that they never saw the day.
So that's one thing.
They had to go to the mines and then they have,
they'd like narc coal off the walls.
That's hard with hammers and picks and all of that and they had to move it.
But that was,
that was their job.
But there was the commute.
So here was the commute.
So imagine that the typical tunnel was about that high,
something like that.
And the typical coal miner was about that high.
Lots of problem.
A,
because you've got to walk through those titles to get to work.
So you have to walk like this.
Then the question might be,
well how far do you have to walk to work?
And the answer is three and a half miles.
And that's how far you have to walk back from work after you've put your eight
hour shift and at the coal mine and the you don't get paid for the commute.
And so or well said that was more or less like climbing a small mountain in the
morning before you went to work and then climbing another one at night before
you went home.
And so that was just,
I mean,
believe me,
I'm telling you very little about how tough their lives were,
but that gives you a little flavor.
I said one day like that for a modern person,
you're just your dad k or you wish you were dead anyways.
And so Orwell talks about going up there to stay and terrible places he lived in
while he was up there and the terrible food he ate and,
and the miserable and wretched scenes that he saw.
And here's one of the miserable wretched scenes.
He's on a train through the neighborhoods.
He says,
the train bore me away through the monster scenery of slag heaps,
chimneys piled scrap iron follow of canals,
paths of cindery mud,
criss cross by the Prince of clogs.
This was march,
but the weather had been horribly cold and everywhere there were mounds of black
and snow.
As we move slowly through the outskirts of the town,
we passed row after row of little gray slum houses running at right angles to
the embankment at the back of one of the houses.
A young woman was kneeling on the stones poking a stick up the lead and waste
pipe which ran from the sink inside,
which I suppose was blocked.
I had time to see everything about her.
Her sack apron or clumsy clogs her arms.
Reddened by the cold.
She looked up as the train passed and I was almost near enough to catch your
eye.
She had around Pale face,
the usual exhausted face of the slum girl who's 25 and looks 40 thanks to
miscarriages and drudgery and at war for the second in which I sought the most
desolate,
hopeless expression I've ever seen.
It struck me.
Then we meaning the middle class at that time,
our mistake,
and when we say that it isn't the same for them as it would be for us and the
people bread in the slums can imagine nothing but the slums for what I saw on
her face was by no means the ignorant suffering of an animal.
She knew well enough what was happening to her,
understood as well as I did,
how dreadful a destiny it was to be kneeling there in the bitter cold on the
slimy stones of a slum backyard poking a stick up of followed drain pipe.
All right,
so
Orwell rates the first part of the book and it details the lives of these people
and then he makes an argument,
he says like,
how can you read about this?
How can you know about this without having sympathy for
redistribution schemes and social and socialist ideas?
And so he's actually asking himself this question.
It's not just a rhetorical question.
He's,
I mean,
he's a serious guy,
right?
He went,
he goes up there and he tells you a story that you have to have a heart of
stone.
If you,
if you don't,
if you read that,
you don't think,
man,
something should be done about this.
It's really awful.
So he set up this situation where your sympathies are completely with the people
that he's describing.
But socialism wasn't all that popular in Britain at that time.
And,
and so,
and socialists weren't all that popular with Orwell.
He didn't really like them that much and he was trying to figure out why that
was.
Okay.
So this is what he wrote in the second part of the book.
Now this God,
I'm in a lot of trouble.
They didn't want to publish this damn book after we wrote the second part.
Uh,
but he fought with him and he got it published and it's a classic and people
still read it and you should read it because it's a great book and Orwell's a
great writer.
And we're well as another one of those people and intellectuals who woke up
pretty early,
you know,
or well wrote animal farm in 1984 he wrote in 1984 in 1948 wrote animal farm
approximately around the same time.
He knew what was happening under Stalin.
And he wasn't afraid to say it,
but it was a message that in some sense fell on deaf ears,
especially among the intelligentsia.
And there's complicated reasons for that.
But,
um,
but it wasn't like the facts weren't there for people to see them if they wanted
to.
And has already said Muggeridge Malcolm Muggeridge had made it pretty clear in
the 1920s and that was widely publicized by the way,
throughout the UK,
what was happening during de [inaudible],
the kulaks being the farmers that I talked about earlier,
who,
who had committed the unspeakable sin of crawling out of their surf status over
a couple of generations to the point where they weren't mirror property and half
starved.